HiROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: My name is Yoshi.
I am the Head of Business Development in Japan,
I also lead Go Global.
We will talk today as we have already indicated
Google Play is a great place to distribute apps
Media, and you can then choose what you want,
Such as deploying the app anywhere.
But today I want to discuss a framework
Go Global.
This process looks more like designing a framework for this segment.
I would then explain each section in detail,
And what should be thought about to achieve a global start.
After explaining the Go Global framework,
Today we will invite the amazing participants
To ask some questions about their Go Global strategies.
Let us follow the explanation.
The first point is choosing the right market.
It is the most important point in strategy.
The market here is stable
Which we call mature market.
There are also emerging markets,
Which we call an emerging market.
For example, a stable market
Are the markets of the United States, Korea and Taiwan.
They contain a lot of special elements.
But the value of the item increases per user.
The rising market is an investment market
And quiet, compared to the US and Japanese market,
The size of the investment is not great.
However, the user base will grow rapidly,
But is now growing very rapidly.
Thus, we have divided the markets into two categories.
Also, as you know, each market has a different face.
For example, the US market has different marketing areas,
Such as different preferences for users and the Japanese market.
The Korean market also has its own marketing areas.
Therefore, each market segment differs from the other.
Also, the same applies to each country,
There are different faces for each.
So, let's get to know each country by market.
For example, the Japanese market.
This is the top ranking in the Japanese market,
It seems that all or most Japanese developers
At the top of the arrangement, it's supposed to be here.
It seems that the use of attractive symbols is common in the Japanese market,
So you may need to use attractive characters or attractive characters
In your applications which is a good thing to attract Japanese users.
Then we move on to the Korean market.
It seems that a lot of Western developers
They have done well, they are at the top of the rankings.
At the top of the ranking were some applications with attractive characters,
And also some applications with serious characters.
This is for the Korean market.
Let's move on to an emerging market.
It is the Brazilian market.
It seems that a lot of Western developers have done
Well done in the Brazilian market,
Applications such as Clash of Clans and Clash of Kings appear to be
And Summoner's War has been successful in the market.
Therefore, these types of competition applications between player and player (PvP),
Applications from the import market look similar.
This is in relation to the Brazilian market.
We then move on to the Indonesian market.
It looks similar to the Brazilian market,
But we can see more apps with attractive characters and attractive icons here.
So we can say it is a mixed market.
So we must understand these specific elements of each market
Then decide which of those markets
You should go to it.
So that we can choose the right market.
We then turn to planning the methodology.
Having decided to move to a certain market such as the Japanese market
Or Korean, you will need to know
How to feed this market.
Can original titles and original drawings be retained?
When you move to this market, you must change graphics
When you move to this market?
This is a decision that needs to be taken.
This is the Asian model and Western model.
The Asian model is more attractive and has a complex user interface, however
More efficient and the display is in vertical mode.
The Western model is more like the user interfaces
The most simple and which are displayed horizontally.
This is for games.
Also, multidimensional design is well-coordinated everywhere.
You will need to customize your services locally,
However, the design must be wiser, and you will not need to know much about it.
Use the multidimensional design because it is more efficient.
We then move on to the next point.
Your apps should be localized and not translated.
This is also a very important part.
Therefore, we define the first, second or third level
According to local naturalization processes.
The first level is simple.
Just go to the market.
Select your app quickly
To post it to these markets, then note how things go.
The second level is more local.
For example, you will need to change the descriptions
To local languages, or change screen shots
Or change the symbols in a manner commensurate with the market,
Then, change the application texts to local languages.
This is the second level.
The third level is the shift to offering the product as an original product.
This includes providing more relevant local content.
For example, place the appropriate content locally in
Your application, like Japanese characters
Or one of the Korean events at this third level.
So, you can get more users - so think about local users.
This is level I, II and III.
Thus, you can scale from Level 1 to Level 2 or Level 3,
Or move to the third level directly from the beginning.
However, we recommend that you review the locally adapted description
Using verification by native speaker.
Therefore, if the check is not performed by a native speaker,
The product will look from the point of view of local users
Like those pictures.
The graphics are good.
The sound is wonderful.
Localized versions have a question mark.
This is from the point of view of local users.
Therefore, we recommend using native language verification on this side.
Native speakers provide more graphics and sounds and localization version
Cool.
This is just a metaphor, but it illustrates the point of view of local users
On the release without a check.
These are my suggestions for the stores.
You've distinguished between your store listing and in-app games.
Here we mention Japan, Korea, Taiwan, Hong Kong, Brazil, Indonesia.
We have recommended the languages ​​that we need
Localized for users.
This is my opinion, which is very clear as you can see,
But make sure you move to this market.
After that, the product must be adapted locally - and this is Musixmatch's success story.
Developers have locally adapted the application. We have discussed a lot of elements about the Japanese market,
They have changed their video ad sections, titles and icons
Description and main images on the screenshot.
They put local talent and content,
Then they put the local languages ​​in the screenshot.
Thus they obtained the number one ranking
In the music category in Japan of the total 50.
I also recommend not only localization,
But also recommended thinking about communication
In each market.
If you want to move to an emerging market,
You'll need to know the speed of the connection as well.
For example, a smaller APK may be
More suitable for those emerging markets.
After downloading, consider the size of a file
Content, or the appropriate data type for the user
And also taking into account domestic prices.
As we mentioned earlier,
These are the types of KPIs you should know
If you want to move to the emerging market.
We turn to the support of local users.
This process is easier, but should support local users
In their local languages.
This is an important fact to move to the local market.
This is a Korean developer
Responds to users in Japanese.
This is important if you want to launch internationally.
Product introduction, testing and replication.
We talk at this point about things like testing and testing A / B,
Channel acquisition and localization processes as well,
This process means keeping up the work,
Keep up and improve.
So, this episode is also important to launch internationally.
Here's a good example of apps.
Experiments have been conducted on the Play Developer Console,
The winning application code was the most simple symbol,
Where the download rate was 41% in Korea.
Also this screenshot of the game.
Earlier, developers tried different types of screenshots,
They got a good number of results and then improved.
Therefore, it is an A / B testing procedure and testing
Something important to check localization versions
Or adapting English screen shots according to the global launch project strategies.
This screenshot before and after the final improvements.
They put in the game all the numbers of well-improved results.
Then change the screen shot.
You can take advantage of local market experts.
We have many people in this place.
So, please communicate with these people to take advantage of them,
You can then ask me about your strategy elements.
So, we get to the end of the presentation.
thank you
[clap]
[Music playing]